who would you say is more pro-trump
um DeSantis or lake Lake okay is it even
a question no she said the other day my
second my husband is my my second
favorite person
she says because my favorite person is
Trump okay so it's fair to say she's
more pro-trump right than the scientist
right is it fair to say that Lake Trump
and DeSantis all have similar backbones
yes okay they're all tough they're not
lightweights you can't push them around
She's Not Afraid the Santa is not afraid
and obviously Trump Is Not Afraid okay
if if you had to choose between those
two as a VP for Trump which one would
you choose
I would choose DeSantis but I can also
see that there is a there could be a
personality weakness that will cause
Trump to pick Lake in other words it's a
personality weakness if somebody is all
about the flattery it's a personality
weakness if someone says I need to pick
the person who thinks I'm the greatest
and if that is Trump's Soul metric and
there are some people who think it is he
will pick like for that reason but what
I'm saying is that if Trump is thinking
in terms of his own best interest and
his own best interest alone then he will
say that look there were things that I
didn't do the last time I've got to be
honest about my own presidency I should
have fired Comey on day one I would have
avoided myself a whole lot of problems
had I done that I should have gotten rid
of Christopher Ray I need an inside
administrative guy who is a massive ass
kicker and I need someone who has the
experience of doing that and would have
the trust of the Republican base that
they will do that for me who's that guy
that's going to be DeSantis Carrie lake
is a newcomer she's a newscaster she's
going to be a first term let's just say
she wins she'll be a first term Governor
let her get her experience there's
probably gonna be I mean hey you talk
about 12 years they could be a de Santa
scary Lake ticket 12 years from now so
in other words these people have not in
12 years four years from now six years
from now yeah so I'm just saying there
are options down the road but I would if
I were Trump I would not go with
somebody as new as Carrie like now let
me give you the DeSantis argument for
the people that are pro de santis I I
fully understand the uh uh pro-trump
argument I understand the like argument
let's talk about the descentesis
argument people who are in his ear okay
there's a difference between who gives
me advice versus what I know what's
going on meaning people can tell me pal
let me tell you here here's who you are
you're so this you're so down like we're
not there yet we're three years away but
I appreciate the compliment but we're
not there yet right
who do you what do you think people
around the centers are telling them you
think they're telling them I think if
Trump calls you as a VP you take it I
think you start negotiating right now
with Trump for you to be the VP or do
you think people on this Camp are saying
everybody in America is modeling after
your state the chances of having this
opportunity again may not happen for a
long time because we're going to forget
about covet in six years because 2024
you got 2028 ain't nobody talking covet
in 2028 they're going to be like dude
kovit was 10 years ago because in 27
2028 it's going to be what seven eight
years ago right people are over it
they've moved on by that time so if he
runs on his record of covet in 2027-2028
nothing's going to happen there right
and then if he you know and then you
know if he sits and waits and then he
runs on the uh you know the his record
as a governor under Trump they're going
to say well because Trump was a
president it wasn't really you it's
because Trump trump was really the
president this is your time to run you
out around so as much as you know many
Republicans I'm sure think a trump
DeSantis ticket is game over yes I also
don't know the council that's being
given to the centers behind closed doors
is hey you you should be open to the
number two idea rather than the number
one idea I don't know if I see that I
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
foreign
[Music]